It's very easy to romanticize nature,
especially if you're a city dweller
who's never had to,
you know,
wander out in the northern woods in the
middle of the summer and get eaten by
black flies and mosquitoes starving to
death while trying to track down an
animal.
It's very easy to romanticize nature.
Of course,
cancer and other diseases tend to
disabuse you of the pure beauty of
nature and nature is a very,
very destructive force.
It's,
it's against us all the time as well as
for us,
and another thing that's really not well
balanced in our society is the anti
humanism that's become part and parcel
of radical discussions everywhere.
Human beings are regarded as a cancer on
the planet.
To quote the what was that?
The Club of Rome worrying about the
population explosion and we're all
guilty because we're destroying things
as fast as we can possibly manage.
It's like Jesus,
everything around us is always trying to
kill us.
Most of the time we're just trying to
stay alive.
I mean we're not perfect.
We're corrupt and sore or social
structures and people get greedy and
careless,
but it's not like nature's all shining.
A wonderful young lady waiting in the
wilderness to embrace us positively.
It's the old hag that's going to kill
you every possible way and you need to
defend yourself against that.
And you know,
human beings have only been in the
position since 1960 since we ever had
any conceptualization of our potential
to change the planet on a planetary
scale.
It's been like four generations,
you know,
back in the eighties and nineties.
Thomas Huxley was commissioned by the
English parliament to,
to investigate the carrying capacity of
the oceans and his.
He was a great biologist.
His report was that there are so damn
many fish in the ocean that every human
being could fish every day for the rest
of his life and catch everything he
possibly could and we wouldn't put a
dent in it.
And that's,
you know,
that's only a 120 years ago.
We only woke up to the fact that we
became a planetary force.
And in 19 six states like,
what the hell do you expect from people
you know,
we're trying to get herself together as
fast as we can and might be decent of us
to stop with the anti human rhetoric,
which is only going to lead to a bad
end.
You know,
if human beings are nothing but a cancer
on the planet,
then it's the bloody hero who
obliterates them.
Isn't that because it's the hero.
He gets rid of cancer.
And when people watch the school
shooters in the mass shooters and they
think,
well,
what is it that motivates people like
that in which they could figure out
about half an hour if they did the
proper reading,
just read what they wrote.
Human beings are a cancer on the planet.
Being as evil.
Intrinsically,
I'm going to take out everything I can
to show my displeasure with the
structure of reality and then I'm going
to shoot myself just to show you how
little I care.
And if you can't understand that,
then you haven't looked very deeply into
your own heart because there could be a
time in your life.
Believe me,
where something terrible happens to you
so that you'll be able to understand
that perfectly.